depuis une semaine et un homme qui fait
le buzz sur tik tok en se faisant passer
pour tom cruise
grâce à la technologie du diptyque les
vidéos de son incroyable tellement
incroyable qu'elles ne peuvent pas être
détectées par les vérificateurs de
dicter way lady paix qu'on va rappeler
ce que c'est guillaume gentil c'est une
vidéo en fait qui ressemble à une vidéo
normal mais les labiale l'expression du
visage sont refaites par une application
dont on peut faire dire n'importe quoi à
tom cruise par exemple regarder c'était
dans le 12 45 de m6 plusieurs vidéos
circulent en ce moment sur tik tok hun
sur ces vidéos il ne s'agit pas de tom
cruise
ce sont des deep fake le visage original
a été remplacé par celui de tom cruise
le réalisme est assez impressionnant
puisque même la plateforme deepwater qui
permet en principe de détecter les deep
tech et bien vous le voyez elle n'y a vu
que du feu
et pour cause c'est l'acteur américain
mike fisher qui pourrait être à
l'origine de ces dites fait qu'il a
plusieurs avantages notamment celui de
ressembler à tom cruise et puis aussi
d'avoir travaillé ses manières sa voix
et son rire il s'était déjà glissé dans
la peau de tom cruise mais avec son vrai
visage pour un canular vous le voyez
annonçant la candidature de la star de
mission impossible à la présidentielle
alors ça s'est inquièté cette
technologie du detec se répondent de
plus en plus avec nicolas canteloup
notamment mais aussi sur une france 3
plus belle la vie regardez ce sujet du
12/13 sur trois a priori vous n'y
verrait que du feu
contrairement aux apparences l'actrice
malika à la wii n'a pas joué cette scène
son visage a été incrustés sur le corps
d'une autre comédienne une astuce
utilisée par la production de plus belle
la vie pour pallier l'absence de malika
ici à droite qu'à contacter au co vide
est donc interdit de tournage pour sept
jours pour plus belle la vie le recours
à cette technologie coûteuse devrait
rester très exceptionnel est à manier
avec précaution il y a deux ans une
vidéo trafic et de barack obama avait
montré qu'on pouvait désormais faire
dire à n'importe qui le président de
trompeta need you up n'importe quoi
j'avais alors je tiens à vous dire un
truc aussi un truc que je voulais vous
dire depuis très très longtemps les
chéris sachez qu'ici il n'ya que cette
technique l'acca et emploie une dizaine
d'années avec toutes les conneries ça va
tellement loin que les médias français
sont en train de travailler depuis
quelques mois sur un logiciel pour
tracter dans l'âge
france presse tente de repérer les
vidéos truquées c'est amusant mais
parfois c'est très grave
il ya un chercheur français qui est en
train de mettre un système peut-être
révolutionnaire en travaillant sur le
mouvement des paupières peut-être que 10
fait n'arriverait pas à reproduire le
vrai mouvement des paupières baissées et
ça pose vraiment n'est pas venu alors
c'est sûr qu'il y arrivera pas moi
j'aimerais que c'est impossible mais je
crois que la prochaine émission de
ardisson a été a été fait grâce à cette
technique afin d'élire biolab soldats
d'hommes qui sont petits qui sont morts
mais bon tout refait intégralement toute
l'interview de ces accords une info
comme c'est le bush fait que ça arrive
moi c'est fou c'est que ça va aussi
ébranlé toutes les procédures
judiciaires les vies des nations sont
apporté comme preuve nulle que la
présence de quelqu'un un tel endroit et
c'est la perdre la partie adverse là les
victimes pourraient dire c'est une
fausse vidéo c'est un teamfight ça ne
peut pas moins sur la vidéo c'est
incroyable mais un chemin assez chaud